no we cannot say I brought you a key
back and give up or hooray for the glory
if you are plenty of any single so last
time I was asking me to tell me what do
you like and you are saying they are
teaching me yeah not for example he
jumped in a pizza or whatever you like
literally means let's let me get a pizza
return it it means pizza this place is
Miss pleasing to me young to me so this
me stands for ah man um is the
proposition to Matt me so little kid
they're very sad Sanford and typically
they say I met me get a pizza they don't
know they emphasize emedny which is
incorrect you are going to do them okay
he's a me piace la pizza and then you
know that me stands for I make if I
wanted to say that so let's say mmm I
like peppers that's cool you remember
how to say peppers they don't yeah then
you would save me piatra captain yes
babe throw deep you can use this
expression also to say that you like to
do something for example i can say me
piace pucci nada cuz it's gotta go
tomorrow tickets are in charge okay so
you used me captain with the dignity
we're going to studies nerves so these
are a very important first without go
esta
seems to be started to stay and I made
it to have what is the difference
between s sarah & spa in general you
have the distinction in English you have
the verb to be and then starting means
to city ok so to be s today it's time to
do something about yourself which is
quite per month for example y so know
that Jana ok or you can say something
about what you can say is that I'm
saying I'm saying yo Nicky amo powder I
can say so no power which is quite
program later I don't change usually
from time to time ok stat it is referred
to both to the location for example you
stop soon la sabia but I can also say
your soul soon aceite so when I do use
static but in some expressions for
example with the adverbs been a male may
your Venture the feeling of the class I
was asking you come i started and you
answered bail i would say stop Benny not
solo babe you're not always happening
yeah that's the other thing I told you
that typically use the verb as Sarah for
more for many things but it's not always
the case for example if I am sick it's
not permanent hopefully but i still use
the word by accident I'd say so no imma
laugh oh so no matta or I'm happy so no
eating using ability okay which is
temporary but you still use the word
access code it's like question of
justice in practice you will find out
when you use of static and will to use
news s-sir stardom you can use it for
example with the journey to say that
something is going on at a given time
for example your stop but lambda what am
I going you're talking yeah so I I say
stop by Marvel not the sort of a man c
english you use the verb to be in
Italian you use the verb start just a
stop I'm a little stop I'm John Doe stop
fuccin and up the nice look and so on so
let's review say indicative of resent
that can you get the presence of the
word essay yes now here I have two
versions to say and slay it okay how
come that I have two versions points for
malaria
yeah so to say it's for not me like that
is formal if I want to ask one of you
for money how are you I say like only
stop not to come it's time that's too so
let's in a row okay yeah you're really
perfecto okay so let's do the very
Nevada for the library you see we have
some HS but the HD ballon is silent so I
don't say oh I just say oh oh oh ok Sam
look at that it's your turn o our that
ah how do you oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
perfect these verbs are irregular and it
may be a little bit tricky to use that
much we'll get used on the other hand
here I have regular verbs so we have six
degrees of regular verbs those that end
with Eric Eric either this is also my
personal suggestion on how to survive at
MIT
you need to run Jaromir what did I say
oh sweet on me okay manchaca hmm your
momjo good we'll do it so I'm down them
yes you want to use the verb started
right now i'm eating stop my dad go ok
let's start from the beginning my job
yeah ok this is the one that's always
confusing man ok if I am talking for me
to grant this week in this movie and I'm
telling him you eat how could I say for
money oh man named memory let me have my
money Giganta i saw i use the third
person even if i'm talking to he became
so it's not safe in a row 33 be really
greatly on oh look at you no no yeah
yeah yeah no Tommy this is not moving me
turn it on
dormia to move done hormonal my magic
River Oregon regional draperies okay I'm
John oh ma eternal tomorrow don't
breathe a benefit under mobile and young
mother here that woman chato and young
member
you